bonsoir je m'appelle nathanaël et je
suis un migrant entre l'âge de 5 ans et
l'âge de 25 ans j'ai vécu dans plus de
six pays différents
je suis né au brésil je suis allé au
mali en passant par la thaïlande
le sri lanka le maroc est un jour
arriver en france et ça a été absolument
une expérience incroyable j'ai des amis
maintenant du monde entier j'ai vécu des
expériences atypique très différente
c'est moi qui vais à l'école et je sais
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai un peu le j'ai pris
de mauvaises habitudes c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai du mal à me poser et
je ne rêve que d'une chose c'est de la
prochaine fois que je vais habiter à
l'étranger je rêverais d'habiter en
thaïlande pays dans lequel de
réhabiliter en thaïlande pays dans
lequel j'ai vécu plus de sept ans et
dans lequel je me sens réellement à la
maison de même je pourrais faire
n'importe quoi pour revivre au maroc
pays que j'appelle de brésil pas très
loin dans lequel j'ai retrouvé la joie
de vivre et l'hospitalité qui
caractérise si bien mon pays d'origine
et aujourd'hui j'aimerais parler avec
vous de la raison pour laquelle je me
suis sentie si bien dans ces pays là
la première raison c'est tout simplement
que je suis un type je fais partie d'un
type de migrants assez spécifique qu'on
appelle les expats mon père donc que
vous voyez sur cette photo a voyagé à
travers le monde pour son travail il
était ingénieur dans le développement et
donc nous on l'a suivi et le titre
d'expats permet de donner une certaine
responsabilité de respectabilité aux
personnes qui le porte et donc
indirectement à moi aussi
et ça ça nous a vraiment aidés à être
acceptés dans les pays dans lequel on
n'allait pas ce qu'on nous reconnaissait
la valeur ajoutée que apporter mon père
au sein de cette société
la deuxième raison pour laquelle je me
suis sentie si bien dans ces pays là
c'est tout simplement parce que j'ai pu
partir à la rencontre de ces pays j'ai
appris le bambara au mali le thaïlandais
en thaïlande et j'ai pu du coup entamer
de vraies rencontres avec la société
j'ai pu en apprendre plus sur les codes
sociaux culturels sur les
fonctionnements de ces sociétés et ses
rencontres elles m'ont permis de
développer un sentiment d'appartenance
de me sentir comme si comme si ces pays
en fait c'était c'était chez moi c'était
dunkerque c'était montpellier c'était
paris je suis chez moi n'importe où
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé à
m'engager je sentais que j'avais quelque
chose à rendre que quelque chose que je
devais remercié les pays dans lequel
j'habitais et cet engagement
il m'a amené ici dans un village karen
dans le nord de la thaïlande
les carènes sont un peuple de birmanie
persécuté en raison de leur ethnie et de
leurs différences et qui pour beaucoup
se sont réfugiés en thaïlande
et quelle a été ma surprise de voir que
ces étrangers
ces migrants eux n'étaient pas aussi
bien accueilli que moi en thaïlande eux
été traité de tous les maux on les
accusait de venir prendre les emplois de
venir créer du crime de venir créer des
problèmes en somme et je ne comprenais
pas comment ces personnes que je
rencontre et avec qui j'ai passé
plusieurs semaines qu'ils se lever tous
les jours à 5 heures du matin ce qui
pour moi était un peu dingue comment ces
personnes là pouvaient être accusés de
vouloir profiter des pays dans lesquels
elles étaient ces personnes elles sont
réfugiés c'est à dire aujourd'hui plus
de 19 millions à travers le monde
sur ces 19 millions plus de 80 % sont
dans des pays en voie de développement
c'est à dire assez loin de chez nous la
france elle accueille environ 200000
personnes aujourd'hui en france à qui
elle a donné le statut de réfugié c'est
à dire un permis de séjour et de travail
qui donne aux réfugiés les mêmes droits
que nous sensiblement à part le vo2 le
droit de vote
ça constitue donc 0,03 % de notre
population
autant vous dire qu'on est un peu loin
de l'invasion et pourtant lorsque vous
voyez le répertoire de mots utilisés
pour partait pour parler des réfugiés il
est très négatif
on parle des réfugiés comme en thaïlande
comme des personnes qui viendraient
profiter de la situation extrêmement
favorable dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui qui viendraient profiter de
nos allocations qui viendraient poser
des problèmes de sécurité
d'ailleurs le ministère de l'intérieur
s'occupe des réfugiés ce qui est très
assez évocateur et qui viendrait du coup
coûter de l'argent à l'état et ce
répertoire là il va avoir un impact très
négatif sur les personnes réfugiées
parce que le réfugié va tout de suite
assimiler un pauvre à une personne
incapable de contribuer et j'aimerais
vous montrer comment est ce que ce n'est
que ce répertoire à un impact concret
sur la vie des gens
je vous présente ce riani three and i
est arrivé il ya 12 ans du sri lanka sa
famille et elles ont fui la guerre
civile qui qui a détruit ce pays est
elle arrivée en france avec un diplôme
de comptabilité et le prix de meilleur
pâtissière de son pays
malheureusement lorsqu'elle est arrivée
en france on le dit mais madame c'est
très bien mais vous ne parlait pas
français
vous allez donc devoir faire des petits
boulots le temps d'apprendre à parler
français
et puis après on verra on verra et c'est
ce que ce rien n'y a fait pendant dix
ans elle a fait des petits boulots qui
ne demandait pas ce qu'elle sache parler
français lorsqu'elle rentrait chez elle
le soir sauf riani était crevé je sais
pas si vous avez déjà essayé de parler
une autre langue que la vôtre le soir
c'est une chose très difficile et donc
ses enfants qui eux allés à l'école ont
commencé à prendre la relève ont
commencé à l'aider sur les aspects
administratifs à l'accompagner lors des
rendez-vous et three and i elle s'est
repliée sur les seules personnes avec
qui elle avait un contact c'est-à-dire
les gens qui parlaient sa langue
et donc elle a complètement mis de côté
ses objectifs son objectif de créer un
jour une activité de traiteur et de
pâtisserie il y a deux ans free a mis à
rencontrer la communauté singh a thing
as c'est une communauté de plus de 15000
personnes dans laquelle on va mettre en
relation des personnes réfugiées comme
three and i qui ont un projet
professionnel entreprenariale
artistiques ou culturelles avec des
français vous moi des citoyens d'autres
citoyens qui ont les mêmes passions et
les mêmes centres d'intérêts
l'objectif est tout simplement non
seulement d'apporter à surya ni un
accompagnement beaucoup plus adapté et
aux autres portant le projet un
accompagnement beaucoup beaucoup plus
adapté tout simplement parce que je ne
suis pas sûr que la dame de pôle emploi
sache comment a accompagné un groupe de
rap et aussi pour faire évoluer ce
regard de la société qui voit se réunit
aujourd'hui comme une pauvre lui donner
le statut d'expats que nous on a
lorsqu'on va à l'étranger et c'est ça
l'objectif de la communauté sting a
thing as également une communauté dans
laquelle on innove dans laquelle on va
apporter des nouvelles solutions grâce
aux réfugiés de la communauté pour vous
donner un exemple il y a maintenant
quatre mois nous avons créé calme la
première plateforme de mise en relation
entre les réfugiés mal logés ou non
logés avec des particuliers et la succès
quelque peu inattendue en deux mois nous
avons reçu plus de douze mille
propositions de logement dans toute la
france une preuve s'il en faut que les
français aujourd'hui veulent s'engager
sur cette question et cette idée on l'a
eue parce que nous avons rencontré
carlos carlos réfugiés colombiens qui
aujourd'hui est président de singh a qui
nous a raconté que justement lorsqu'il
est arrivé en france il avait passé deux
ans dans une famille et que cette
expérience l'avait aidé à apprendre le
français à mieux comprendre la société
dans lequel il se trouvait et a
développé un réseau social et
professionnel
chose qui est très importante et donc ce
que j'aimerais vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est que l'accueil
ce n'est pas une quelque chose qu'on
fait par pitié c'est une chose qu'on
fait par humanité
mais aussi par bon sens lorsqu'on
accueille bien lorsqu'on permet à une
personne de partager avec la société ses
talents ses compétences ses expériences
c'est toute la société qui sort gagnante
l'accueil c'est quelque chose de très
simple c'est tout simplement accepté une
rencontre un dialogue et plus si
affinités merci